quant à l'école primaire on découvre la
france en en décidant la carte les
landes séduisent d'emblée tous les
petits écoliers
car elles sont le plus facile à dessiner
un trait tout droit droit comme une côte
sableuse
en réalité ce sable s'étend sans
discontinuité sur plus de 100 kilomètres
avec ses avantages et ses inconvénients
ses inconvénients
une mère au rouleau dangereux pour les
imprudents inoubliable pour les autres
surfeurs en particulier ce sable à
l'étang nu presque illimitées favorise
comme l'ensemble du département les
vacances dites familiales fête de mères
de soleil de promenade à l'ombre des
pins et de nourriture copieuse ce que
certains qualifient de vraies vacances
d'ailleurs si l'on excepte cas breton
les landes ne sont pas un département
d'où l'on part pour de longues
croisières maritimes pour offrir ses
vraies vacances la population landaise
peut augmenter de 50%
un peu plus de trois cent mille
habitants quand il pleut en hiver 450000
en été sous le soleil
le camping est la solution la plus
accueillante avec ses 55 mille places
offertes les résidences secondaires
viennent ensuite trente six mille lits
puis l'hébergement type associatif comme
les villages vacances ou les colonies
avec dix sept mille places l'hôtellerie
pour sa part propose dix mille lits en
1982 les professionnels du tourisme ont
recensé plus de 15 millions de nuitées
si la mer vous semble trop turbulente
rejoignez les lacs idéal pour la planche
à voile depuis deux ans maintenant une
nouvelle station a su allier les deux
maires et lacs vieux boucau port
d'albret la station nouvelles de la côte
landaise capable de multiplier sa
population parfum chaque année 20 nous
avons par exemple tous les arts en
moyenne 150 à 200 appartements qui sont
mis à nouveau sur le marché
également à peu près voyez cette année
il y aura sur port d'albret environ 100
places de villages de vacances
supplémentaires par rapport à l'an
dernier
alors là je pense qu'effectivement bon
mais nous pouvons accueillir
beaucoup plus de touristes que nous
n'allons environ l'an dernier et je
pense que justement puisque cette année
on suppose que nous aurons à faire un
afflux de touristes très important du
fait évidemment des raisons que vous
connaissez la mosson mon prêt et nous
pouvons les accueillir comme partout en
france les landes ont entendu l'appel
lancé par le gouvernement
passez vos vacances en france et dans
les landes comme au pays basque
d'ailleurs l'augmentation de la demande
n'a pas encore été très sensible pour
juillet et où tout est retenu depuis
longtemps comme chaque année seul le
camping permettra d'absorber la demande
supplémentaire